all right everybody it's late some talk
loud to keep you guys awake
I'm Jim Jim young I'm tall
I'm the engineer I'm talking about
testing and the build process yeah I can
hear the growth inside people like
testing oh man that size I know right
but I'm gonna tell you why does it suck
that much all right testing why bother
right right you're saying Jim I'm gonna
scrap you start off we're gonna change
the world
oh I don't need a test we need it
iterate fast you know break things
that's what they say Google yeah I was
like that too at one time you don't want
to be do this when your code goes down
yeah so when I say testing what sort of
testament talking about
I remember a school there like Jim you
need to know about black box testing
white box sex thing regressions have
seen folks on testing all the sort of
testing I'm like man I am gonna be the
baddest engineer alive I don't write any
bugs the people I work with you already
bugs and I'm gonna test that's all bull
so bold right get the more mature
engineer I become so I realize I didn't
know jack when I was in school and now I
know so yeah you want to write tests
so why test the unit tests the most
basic level of nesting tests of function
essentially so anybody can see what's
the air in this cold front it's okay
it's really small so the problem is this
return of
next return to strength so simple like
lensing or static analysis wouldn't
catch that but in unit test which takes
30 seconds to write what I thought that
in a second so that's one reason why
t-test to catch easy errors like that
switch the unit test and then test so
your pipeline I'm sure is ours is very
complicated it's long so the part can
write your code to actually deploying
you live it's probably many many steps
so a long way stuff to break so and the
end tests help test like did your code
actually make it live and is it what the
usuals to see so and this tester good
I'll talk a little bit more about this
but uh and then up that button should
have been blue now it's in red right now
I'll tell you a little bit about our
stack we use Jasmine Jasmine is a
testing framework very popular I'm sure
you use it comparable to say mocha or QE
that stuff like that we use karma
Karma's test runner for those not
familiar karma essentially aggregates
all your files thirds and that jasmine
and I have some nice configurations but
karma was kind of good fact ago Seuss
perfected protractor those are end and
written by and give the guys also uses
jasmine so another good reason to use
jasmine Jenkins Jenkins our continuous
integration server very popular as well
Oh get more into that later ah and
selenium plenty of runs are our pair
tests and you're saying what's the
pinger well the code that when you go to
new york times that gets loaded up
litter BJ's code that's our ping arenít
essentially pings back to us and we test
that pretty thoroughly this isn't about
that that's not really an angular it's
written in vanilla JavaScript but it's
downloaded over two hundred seventy
seven billion times and years so you
want to make sure it works so if it
breaks for even like a day that's
millions of people that the code isn't
work right for some talk about some easy
wins with angularjs testing because
really like I don't want our test but if
I do I want to learn how to do it better
cool I'm the man to talk to you so give
her books
what a web focus few people aren't I
cool alright so especially web book is
you say you say some service like you
know you say hey whenever something
happens call back to this API with some
data that's it it's very simple it's
cool you know hooks you should use them
but if you use github believe gitlab
essentially what happens is when I put
some code in the master github says hey
Jen just put some code the master and
then we can kick off the whole series of
tests to match that so it helps with
integration testing I've used them link
if you want to read about it's really
simple to implement essentially you can
add this but so if the tests fail this
will turn yellow or gray which says like
test failed it's nice way like open pull
request and see you like my code
integrated properly ah make your test
I didn't potent or impotence depending
on where you went to school
ah you're saying what that is that I
wanted the green see it that's cool
essentially means every time you throw
data at a function or something it
should come out the same way every time
and you're saying Oh duh Jim I've been
engineering for years oh I'm sorry I
apologize but so where this comes into
play is like say you have some service
that calls
what are your API that's cool but what
I'm still a connectors are like a test
fill your builds wants no the whole
thing's backed up so you don't want to
use api's for something like it's for
testing like that so what you want to do
is use energy mocks ng box allows you to
say like oh you can fake a back in
essentially so I'm gonna pick a call to
Charpy calm and then return some fake
data to go with that but essentially
means like your test will be the same
every time so that data never changes
because your API doesn't change it's not
a really yeah as far as your promise to
concern it's the fully working in
angular app there's a link to our ng
mock yes
Jr code oh yeah this is one of my
favorites so yeah we'll be Commons man
that's right thing it's all right there
for you um and I'll give you a gem pro
tip if you're ever applying for job at
heartbeat and we give you a Kotex just
common your code promise you'll be top
of the list so many people don't comment
very passionate about this ah
so we used to have stock here for
commenting and you're saying why
comments my codes awesome I'm awesome
you're not so awesome but it's cool
but you probably because like a week
from that you probably not gonna matter
what you did and you're like man I got
ready to test for this well a comment
makes it slow like Oh return it took me
a whole 30 seconds right doc Walker for
those of you not familiar and he used
sublime which renders a popular
front-end tool doc Locker is essentially
slash star star enter and it skeletons
out this whole thing for you so really
don't have a good reason not to be kind
of thing
plus comedy codes just be a full of debt
challenges this will speak but gifts
don't work but as a more expanded
engineer I've also been like what what
are they doing like why do they suck so
bad what I said that's just I won't
confuse guys that's this thing that's
worth anybody's ever trying to test a
directive you're like and this is hard I
cannot contest filter is no problem if
controllers that kiss services but a
trance that's hard man that's a template
that's angular stopping you know don't
worry I'm gonna tell you something how
the template you put in a dominant like
normal yeah it's easy but it's something
a while to figure that out I'm not the
world's smartest fan so it's like a
paradigm shift what I figured is that so
essentially what you want to do is you
take your template board your directive
you compile to an angular element you
append into the dominant you just
compile it just like knowing the angular
would do when you're normally loading a
page so it really I think is tested one
way
things like that but doing that makes
life so much easier that was like the
last big pearl we had old couple in
remand Texas has directives any test
components this is the way to do it no
challenge oh you've got a hundred
thousand tests you have great
engineering team you guys are too like
onyx awesome
but when you run the test that's a good
question well our old friend genius the
continuous integration server and my old
friend Justin let's one of our web ops
he wrote a thing called Justin's which
essentially boiled down Jessica this is
a post-commit hooked listener so
essentially those what looks we talked
about earlier it makes a callback to our
API and that kicks off some build jobs
we say oh yeah that's easy
what Justin's does it's extra special is
it checks the directors that we've
modified it but only runs a test that
she on the code you change so before is
like coping vac all the tests run code
comes back all test run number like
rather running Django tests where I
disclose in JavaScript
Justin's fixed that and it gives you
using uh
Jenkins you can get like a nice stuff
history you can know the build breaks
and generally I'm the guy that finds on
your when you break the bills so that's
what I call a winning combination
production billows talk a little bit
about builds now uh so ship your code
I'm hoping people do something like this
if not that's cool I'm not gonna junkie
but so we have steps to go through your
like JavaScript Java scripts not
compiled I know but there's still stuff
you have to do so you got a Lindsay you
get a queen you got other [ __ ] table
lists and power templates put all
together
push it up a master push it out to your
CD yeah that's a lot of stuff and I'll
tell you I am lazy
I am so lazy you gotta do this
today and that sucks what can we do
about that hmm oh we can use grunts
you're on JavaScript ass runner
notorious now our infamous [ __ ] so ah I
don't know anybody use grub before yeah
it's very popular grunts pretty cool so
we started solves all their problem and
runs all the tests for you um you know
chrome grunt is this configuration files
if someone hasn't built it for you
you're like am i doing man just started
like a nice fix that got em think no
like you look at this and it's not it's
not clear at all so confused guy again
yeah so what you do we switch the gulp
Michael gulp is synchronous or
asynchronous it's streaming so it's
faster and it's simpler because it's
just vanilla JavaScript no configuration
phrases here's a goal task Oh see it's
just a function like anybody can go in
there and say like I want to go up task
to turn all the images on the website
and the kitties your build process done
anyway yeah so gulp is fantastic you
guys are using grunt think about
switching the gulp unless you have like
so another thing forward gulp is we just
have one baseball so as Harry alluded to
earlier all of our products they have
their sorry miss step back we have one
goal plot because because there's
certain things you want to have a time
you want to be able to build compiled
minify of the flash stuff like that so
we have one group go file so each
application has its own build file so
let's say I have something very specific
I need to do for this one dashboard we
can put it in there and three carries
compiled advertising directory this
still has all the functionality
the outside but it has a little bit
extra on top just to make it sweet so
like I said before don't ask for
everything don't ask easy to read it's
just JavaScript literally for all the
front-end they do everything for us and
that's good advices automate everything
you can ah so this is a finished Jenkins
vanilla this is part of our gold bill
and so what we have is we have Jenkins
hooked in the github which compiled Java
code commits it back and then notifies
that notifies our hip chatroom or get
the other ones
thank you yeah or sly whatever you want
like so essentially like it's automated
and it's running in a stew and all its
work for you but you can still be
notified so it's the things I'm just
going crazy and Jenkins throwing out
left and right but again
Jenkins highly recommend it need some
free advice on it I hope come talk to
you for free yeah that's it
I'll take questions later yeah oh I'll
take questions down
so you won't establish like first off
you want establish what you want to test
because then then tests are like so
broad Deming they test pretty much your
entire stack will they test the function
on your tire stack so that's mainly what
we do so I said tell my QA engineer we
say what are you trying to test exactly
we set up some core functionality such
as like your robot that wants to log
into the website every time like you
want to extrapolate that out and so like
you want to make your test so you can
inherit all this stuff and then just
write the functionality you need for
instance like fun testing one dashboard
I rat out a specific test for that but
like overall the site will have code
that I inherit from there
sorry I'm not really oh I'll check that
out yeah definitely end end is like one
of our newer forays and the things like
robot framework uh Dani ensure they got
us walked out to speak more to that um
do we don't these mechanize anything
like that barry no selenium it mainly
runs on what's the big testing grounds
or ears sauce labs thank you you guys
are honest it yeah so runs on sauce
laughs so tests on all the browsers and
selenium just leave just kicks off those
jobs for us
we're like so the screaming kind of like
piping there's a Night Watch guess which
does like webdriver jss language we can
do in to end testing because I found a
protractor to be like a little bit too
pops I'd like a little bit hardcore so
yeah you can just
I'll check that out yeah that is one of
the problems protractor it's very
opinionated on how you should do the
test and I don't know I like a little
flexibility test promises Oh funny story
we actually haven't got that far yet but
I will have another talk when we get to
that for you sorry I'm the test or not
oh we do so mainly for our ping er
because that's our most heavily used
code we test across Helen Ellie how many
different browsers yeah yeah yeah so but
that's one of the things I like needs to
work we we said I like a bare minimum
for competitively for dashboard so I
nine Chrome Firefox Safari that's pretty
much what test across for our unit tests
not really our Emma 10 tests we do test
across those but
yes lynnium does that oh yeah
that my friend is a great question so
testing is a problem in Sarna because
you know let's face it we all have a
limit amount of the runway and we all
have a certain amount engineering time
we need to get work done so my thing is
like we don't at Sharpie we're pretty
loose on like we're not gonna make you
write tests but it's Jeff definitely
encouraged like but we're not gonna stop
your workflow to write a test our common
stuff is very well tested our products
pretty well test as well but not as well
as I'd like obviously but no I like
there's nothing like making somebody
it's more like we're all like a good
team and we just wouldn't do that to
someone else you know when the code
breaks you're like oh I know it works
for a small team we'll see all the
scales in the future but yeah all right
thanks guys